Hey, it's Molly Webster from radio lab. Before we get into the show today,
I wanted to tell you something and that's it. Radio lab has a newsletter. We do.
It's awesome. You should sign up for it.
You'd be the first to know about new episodes.
You'd get updates on old ones and lots more to sign up.
Go to radiolab.org/newsletter see ya.
This is Radiolab. I'm Jad Abumrad rubber Coolidge today.
Our Program's about music.
We ended our last segment with a a look back at a very famous riot in 1913 in a
composer, Igor Stravinsky,
whose primary objective was to create something new and dissonant and
disturbing.
Right now we'll present the opposite [inaudible],
the Anti Stravinsky anyway, and what we mean is he,
we're going to introduce you to a guy who has invented a new,
radically innovative and ingenious way of creating something.
Oh, interesting. Hey there. Are you rolling? I am rolling.
His name is David Coke.
He works and teaches composition at UC Santa Cruz in California and recently our
producer Ellen Horn was in the area.
It is a beautiful area. It's 22.5 miles. Wow.
And she paid him a visit. It's extraordinary. And they're like birds.
We've got a, we've got, you know, I have nest in each window each year, years.
Sure. And this one's over here. You can just take a look at you, hike,
come back in. It's okay. It's just me. Come on, get back in your nest. Um,
she's usually, she'll just hop right back in when she hears me talk here.
Aren't you gonna listen to me?
Oh, this was beside the point because we'd actually come to talk to David, Cope,
not about nature, but actually about something unnatural that he'd done,
which started about 20 years ago
in 1980, I had a, a commission for an opera,
which involved actual money, which we had been given up front.
And which by the way, since I had four small children, I had already spent.
And uh, for the first time in my life, uh, I suffered a composer's block.
It was like, somebody just shot me and you know, you're,
I should be at the height of my creative power and I can't find a reason to
compose a first note.
The c-sharp decided no more interesting in c natural or d and notes just didn't
make any sense to me. I was really lost.
I can't think of anything worse cause it's not my profession,
it's what I am.
A short time time
later,
David Cope is at a party and he finds himself talking to a guy who programs
computers and he was asking me how things were going and I just simply said,
you know, it's a nightmare. And we talked through it. You know, I,
I think I must have initiated it by saying,
are there any intelligent programs out there that could,
I could possibly use to help me through this? And he said, well,
there aren't any intelligent programs, period. But he said,
you don't really need one. Don't you really just need some kind of a foil.
He called it that. And I,
I really had an epiphany.
What I would do is build not so much composing engine, but an analytical engine,
a computer. It took them years to build it. This is, this is,
this is Emmy right here. This is this and these. The computer's name,
it's spelled e, m. I, m.
E is an acronym for experiments in musical intelligence,
and what he built me to do is analyze things. This is specifically notes,
treat notes like data. In other words, he'll feed me a bunch of sheet music.
For example, buck, Krells,
[inaudible],
any will then convert every single note on the page into numbers.
Can you describe what you see on the screen? Well,
there's subs and thousands of numbers there. Five numbers for each note,
numbers which represent all kinds of things. The on time, the pitch,
the duration chorale becomes a huge mass of information.
Which Emmy then sorts through looking for patterns. Hmm. Nope.
Four 50 always seems to be falling by note, four 56 loud and then soft.
She will find the patterns. Every composer has them, the little things they do,
the DNA of the individual now finding all the patterns,
mapping the creative DNA of a composer is in and of itself.
Not all that interesting. It's what happens next, which is the spooky part.
Cope hits a few buttons and all the DNA starts to recombine.
Ghosts stir in the machine,
any Mahler,
any Beatles,
[inaudible],
Ethan Scott, Joplin
[inaudible]
and of course his favorite Bach
of course.
Then I became very excited about this prospect and immediately put in some coke
and sure enough, my opera, which had taken high on know by the time I was,
I put it in the Copay, it was maybe five years of past, uh,
the opera was written in about 10 days.
So as a demonstration,
I'm going to play for you the opening of a corral that was composed in 1987,
uh, in the style of Bach, one of the first ones that came out of the program.
Now, this corral was so bad, it sounded to me when I first heard it that I,
I um, I threw it away at Britain, the trashcan. And then I said, well,
there's something about that that I kind of like and I pulled it out again.
I thank God I did because this is one of my favorite pieces that program ever
produced. So here's what it sounds like as a machine replant
[inaudible] you can hear the rigidity of the performance, the machine,
like n****r of the meter being processed and all the notes being processed at
precisely the right time with these timbers sooner orders,
which are egregious. I mean, they're just terrible.
[inaudible]
now I'm, I'm going to play for you the same corral as performed, uh,
by a group of singers, a awhile liter [inaudible]
[inaudible]
same person music, incredibly human,
personal musical going someplace intriguing.
I want to hear more of the second one. I'm glad I turned off the first one.
One idea.
[inaudible]
oh yes. So yes. Oh, the number of negative reactions, uh, far, far out number,
the positive reactions. I don't remember recall one in particular, one that,
oh yeah, I was at a conference in Germany in which a colleague,
uh, hit me in the nose with his finger. I'm a,
I'm pretty much at a coward physically, you know, he was bigger than ice.
So it was, it was a quite a moment. But there have been many, many occasions,
you know,
shouting matches if you've spent a good portion of your life being in love with,
you know, these dead composers. I mean that sounds horrible,
but you know what I mean?
And along comes some Twerp who claims to have this little piece of software
would use, isn't in much at all that can, can, can move you in the same way.
Suddenly you're saying to yourself, well,
what's happened here? Certainly my, my,
my relationship to the original pieces of music is cheapened in some way.
I mean,
what is Chopin really just nothing more than a bunch of cliches drum together.
[inaudible]
I hurt with them in a way and when they hurt, um,
I feel successful
and I also feel very bad. I mean,
I'm missing with some pretty powerful relationships here and doing so in a
mechanical way. If I had done it myself as a human being,
these individuals could probably live with it because after all they could say,
well, you know, he's just really good at that sort of thing.
But somehow using hell, you know,
or some version of how is the ultimate insult.
There is nothing intelligent about my program and this lightest.
Nothing intelligent about it.
I could do everything it did if you gave me 10 years.
I just don't have that amount of time. I'd rather spend five minutes.
Thank you very much.
We did a concert here at,
at Amy Bach and the Middle Moon is just a dorm.
I mean it's just lovely. And,
and a friend of mine was sitting in the back of the hall next to an ancient
lady.
She must've been in her eighties late eighties and she couldn't read very well.
So she hadn't read the program notes and she really just was at this concert
because friends told her she didn't know what was all about or anything like
that. But she knew all about music and she loved ball and,
and she listened to that
[inaudible]
and she turned to my friend and said,
oh,
that was just beautiful. And my friends started to say,
but do you know that it was, and then he said,
well, the hell with that.
[inaudible]
it was the reaction that I hope people will have a hundred years from now. If,
if by some weird fluke,
this stuff hangs around long enough to still be around them. Um,
but I hope we can put aside all this machine trapping this stuff and,
and really just deal with the music itself.
[inaudible]
that piece was produced by Jonathan Mitchell and recorded by our producer Ellen
Horn. David Cope composes and teaches at UC Santa Cruz in California.
If you'd like to hear any more compositions by his computer Emmy.
And there are hundreds, you can visit our website,
radiolab.org there you will find Emmy Bach, Amy Chapin, e Scott Joplin,
even Emmy Navajo music.
And the scary part is that much of it is quite good. Emmy Navajo music. Yeah.
Um, my, I guess we should sign off, right? Yes. Ah,
I'm just still thinking about Emmy Navajo music. Actually, you know what?
Let's let Emmy take us out. Oh, this is actually, uh,
your favorite composer as re animated by Emmy,
the Computer Mahler and the mother.
Oh Damn. You know, this is, it's very troubling. This is very choke.
[inaudible]
and for more information on anything you've heard this hour, check our website,
radio lab dot. Oregon. While you're there. Communicate with us. Radio
lab@wnyc.org is the address. This is Radiolab.
I'm Jad Abumrad Robert Krulwich and I am signing off.